alibaba's e-commerce platforms
10 cents video games didi's ride-hailing
service
these are some of china's biggest names
in tech and for the past several years
foreign investors have been pouring
money into their stocks
but this summer those shares listed in
new york and hong kong saw sharp
sell-offs
and it had little to do with their
business performance
china has taken a series of actions
against big tech
and those moves from clamping down on
alleged monopolistic behavior to
tightening rules on data security
have sent shockwaves through
international markets there has been a
sense
amongst chinese officials that some of
these companies have become a bit too
powerful in july alone food delivery app
mei tuan
tencent alibaba and short video app kwai
show lost about
20 percent of their combined market
value a top chinese securities regulator
privately reassured foreign financial
firms that the government would consider
the market impact
of its policy decisions but investors
wonder what the future holds for china's
tech companies
and more broadly for listings of chinese
companies in the us and other countries
the scope and severity of the moves
recently has
taken people back many foreign investors
are kind of asking
okay we thought we knew all the risks
here but everything's actually
worse than we imagined china has stepped
up efforts to rain in big tech
and fast-growing firms like tencent and
bride-hailing app dd which have become
central to everyday life in china
have been subject to the clampdown in
many ways dd is the uber of china
earlier this year dd went public on the
new york stock exchange in a
multi-billion dollar
ipo that was completed in just a few
days it emerged that perhaps they hadn't
got the full
sign-off from the chinese authorities or
at least the chinese authorities had
suggested to them
they might want to hold off partly for
kind of data security reasons
but dd pressed ahead china's regulators
launched a cyber security probe and
suspended dd's apps and said the company
which collects a range of user data
hadn't complied with china's data
protection rules
shortly after its stock plummeted it
kind of
left investors with the sense that didi
had been punished for having the
temerity to go public when it should
perhaps have been
more heedful of what chinese regulators
were saying didi said it would comply
with requirements made by relevant
authorities
last year after billionaire jack ma
publicly called for regulatory changes
chinese authorities targeted ant and
alibaba two firms he's closely
associated with
regulators shut down ant's blockbuster
ipo
which was expected to be the world's
largest public listing
and launched an anti-trust probe into
alibaba
now after all these events markets are
jittery
in august when a state-owned chinese
newspaper criticized online gaming as
opium for the mind
the stock of gaming giant tencent saw a
massive sell-off
tencent also the owner of social media
and messaging platform wechat
has recently come under pressure to
address what authorities are calling
anti-competitive practices
and security issues tencent said it
would introduce new rules including
stricter curbs on younger gamers
[Music]
some investors wonder if chinese
authorities might also target the
mechanism foreign buyers use to invest
in chinese stocks listed offshore
if you're investing in certain u.s
listed chinese companies like alibaba
you're not exactly buying shares
directly in the business
you're buying into an offshore vehicle
that has a series of legal arrangements
with the operations inside china
this setup uses what is known as a vie
or
variable interest entity there are
literally trillions of dollars
worth in market cap of chinese companies
listed abroad
and most of that is done through these
vie structures over time some people
have questioned
because it operates in this kind of gray
area whether the chinese authorities
might one day kind of
decide that they don't like this this
loophole until recently
chinese companies going public in the us
were a bright spot in the otherwise
tumultuous u.s china relationship
and some chinese tech stocks have
produced big gains for foreign
investors in the last few years but now
everyone's watching to see what steps
chinese regulators will take next
year
there is a sense maybe that the chinese
regulators were kind of blindsided by
how severe the foreign reaction was
they don't want to completely close the
door in the outside world and they don't
want to
completely terrify markets but they also
are pretty resolute about what they feel
they need to do and
they feel like this is all good for the
long-term development of the chinese
economy
it seems like the campaign isn't over